all right welcome everybody let's jump
right in uh we haven't done a good
old-fashioned a press briefing wacky
questions segment in a little bit i
checked in on the press briefing that
took place on wednesday this week and
some really pretty wacky stuff is going
on first of all fox news's peter ducey
is still trying to ask these gotchas of
jensaki she's actually increasingly well
prepared to handle them and here is one
where
after some comments joe biden made
peter ducey
is asking whether
if a parent doesn't like their kids
curriculum
they should be considered a domestic
terrorist extremely misleading i'll
explain in a moment does the
administration agree that parents upset
about their kids curriculums
could be considered domestic terrorists
well let me unravel this a little bit
because the national school board
association is not a part of the us
government i'd point you to them what
the department of justice said in a
letter from the attorney general is that
quote threats against public servants
are not only illegal they run counter to
our nation's core values that is true
these were threats against public
servants threats against
members of the school board regardless
of the reasoning
threats and violence against public
servants is illegal now you might be
wondering
what on earth is peter ducey talking
about and what he's talking about is the
mobilization of the federal government
to some degree
on the basis of escalated threats
against educators and the insanity
that's happening at the school board
meetings the problem is not taking
seriously
the behavior of parents at school board
meetings uh that that's what we should
be doing the problem is that
the school board meetings are getting
completely insane and what this entire
thing is in reference to
is that
last week the national school boards
association pressed biden for federal
assistance to review whether violence
and threats against public school
officials
could be
considered a form of domestic terrorism
and hate crimes that's all that this is
about and peter ducey of course has to
make it the most melodramatic thing
possible
then peter ducey tries to make it a free
speech issue
the problem is lunatic parents at the
school board meetings then ducey tries
to make it a free speech issue does
biden support the right to protest of
course he does
does the president support the
fundamental right of these parents to
protest at school board meetings of
course but he doesn't stand for the
fundamental right i assume you don't
either for people to take a violent
action
against members of public servants and
that's what the threats are about and so
no he doesn't stand for that right
it's
one of these after another after another
just continuing to
make something
not out of nothing
but make something
out of what you should be making the
opposite out of why are all of these
parents losing their minds going crazy
at school board meetings attacking
teachers verbally assaulting quoting
hitler as we talked about last week on
and on and on that's really the question
and uh then just one other here's a
bonus one this is a different reporter
saying
why hasn't joe biden called mitch
mcconnell to try to get all of this
stuff sorted out referring to the bills
and the the double standard here is
notable let's listen first
why wouldn't the president given that
relationship he has with mitch mcconnell
just call mitch mcconnell and have this
conversation with him why do this
through what's the conversation about
you're i don't know they have the
relationship he's the one who said you
could bring the two sides together so
wouldn't there be some value in having
that conversation you know what the we
know what the risk-free option is here
we know what the clear path forward is
here uh and i think the president has
made no secret about his belief on that
so
i have no problem with jo i've said it a
million times when joe biden brought
republicans to the white house and some
some people on the left from ads and
people on the right were mad great bring
them give him an opportunity to weigh in
on the covet stimulus build that was
back then
they don't want to participate let them
not participate and ultimately that's
what they did
but you're not going to hold things up
it's fine to talk to them
when it was trump
right
the question was
why won't democrats
give trump what he wants why are
democrats getting in the way why won't
they concede anything at all why why why
even though that was a completely
dishonest framing
now much of the corporate media has
switched to
why isn't joe biden talking to more
republicans
before
the problem was democrats weren't giving
trump what he wanted
now the problem is joe biden hasn't
called mitch mcconnell but a couple
months ago when he actually did meet
with republicans then the problem was
why is he giving republicans so much
power even though he didn't
it's the need to constantly create the
most salacious possible narrative even
if it has very little bearing on reality
so that's the press briefing let's now
talk about christmas
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping